hi this is Kim from Khan Academy today
we're learning more about the landmark
Supreme Court case Dred Scott vs.
Sanford decided in 1857 the ruling in
the Dred Scott case inflamed sectional
tensions over slavery which had been
growing ever more heated over the course
of the 1850s originally a case about
whether one man ought to be free Dred
Scott vs. Sanford transformed into a
case about African American citizenship
and the future of the institution of
slavery itself to learn more I sought
out the help of two experts Christopher
Bracy is a professor of law at the
George Washington University School of
Law he's an expert in u.s. race
relations individual rights and Criminal
Procedure
Timothy Hubner is the Irma o Sternberg
professor of history at Rhodes College
and the author of Liberty and Union the
Civil War era and American
constitutionalism so professor Bracy can
you take us through a little bit just
who was Dred Scott and why did he bring
this case so Dred Scott was born around
1800 and was the slave of Peter and
Elizabeth Taylor blow in 1818 Peter blow
decides to move his family and Dred
Scott to Alabama where he had bought a
cotton plantation that didn't go so well
so he sells the plantation and moves the
family and dread to st. Louis Missouri
where he had purchased a boarding house
called the Jefferson hotel and that
period really was a period during which
the nation was arguing over the status
of slaves and the rights of slaveholders
and the future of slavery in new western
territories and this issue came up in a
very significant way in a very
controversial way in the question of the
future of slavery in the territory and
ultimately the state of Missouri after
two years of arguing over this finally
in 1820 and 1821 a sort of compromise
was set out by members of Congress north
of the southern border of Missouri with
the exception of the state of Missouri
slavery would be banned in 1830
Elizabeth Taylor blow dies and Peter
himself
two years later but before he does he
makes an arrangement to sell Dredd to an
army physician by the name of dr.
Emerson dr. Emerson is an army physician
so he's going to be stationed in a lot
of different places not just in the
slave state of Missouri in fact it turns
out that dr. Emerson's first posting
with Dredd takes him to Fort Armstrong
which is located in Rock Island Illinois
and Illinois of course is a free state
under both federal law and Missouri law
as understood at the time Dredd would
have lost his slave status and become a
free man as soon as he stepped foot on
to free territory this was known as the
extraterritorial emancipation doctrine
it was perfectly legal and perfectly
possible for a slave sojourner a slave
who had been taken into a free state or
free territory to file suit for his
freedom
dr. Emerson marries Eliza Irene Sanford
of st. Louis
dr. Emerson eventually dies in 1843 and
he leaves the entire estate including
the Scott's to mrs. Emerson mrs. Emerson
decides she would like to hire dreadout
to make some money for herself rather
than be hired out Dred offers to
purchase his own freedom and the freedom
of his entire family but mrs. Emerson
refuses to allow dread to buy out the
freedom of his family so Dred Scott
files a civil lawsuit what was called a
freedom suit back then in the Missouri
State Court and his claim was that mrs.
Emerson was falsely imprisoning him and
his family and he was able to do this
with the help of the sons of his former
owners the lawyer is being paid by the
children of Peter and Elizabeth Taylor
Blow dred Scott's first master in the
meantime you have a new development mrs.
Emerson has remarried to Republican
congressman Calvin Chaffee
from Massachusetts and he can't be a
slave owner and still be a Republican
congressman from Massachusetts so mrs.
Emerson transfers title of the Scott's
to her brother John Sanford who is a
resident of New York with business ties
in st. Louis now it was eligible for the
case to go into federal court in that it
in
of people who lived in two different
states so now you might be thinking well
filing a lawsuit against your purported
master that's pretty brave stuff but as
it turns out freedom suits of this
nature were not that uncommon
particularly in border states where the
slavery question was hotly disputed
indeed there were some 300 or so of
these freedom suits that were filed in
Missouri during the period in which Dred
Scott filed his case many people viewed
the Missouri Compromise is not so much
of a compromise but as something that
was forced upon the slave states and
then you've got the Kansas Nebraska Act
which gave similar autonomy to those
areas to decide the slavery question and
whether or not it would be introduced
into those territories interesting so
people in the North who opposed slavery
or at the very least didn't want slavery
to expand would have been looking in the
1850s and saying hey I thought we
already decided this there wouldn't be
slavery north of this line and I are
saying maybe Kansas and Nebraska could
be slave states right and that was a
huge issue in national politics because
northerners are starting to grow very
suspicious of southerners on this
slavery issue they're starting to speak
of what they called the slave power that
southern slaveholders sort of held all
of this power in Washington and that
they were sort of running the show and
this 1854 act had made it possible for
slavery to potentially expand into an
area where previously it had been banned
and you really do get this escalation of
tension and the Fugitive Slave Act of
1850 which basically forced requirements
upon free states to ensure the longevity
of the slave states by requiring them to
undertake certain behaviors in the
return of fugitive slaves only escalated
the tension and concern about the status
of slavery in American life all right so
we're in this incredibly tense time of
the 1850s with the the slavery question
yet unanswered and Dred Scott and his
case gets to the Supreme Court so how
does the Supreme Court Rule on this in a
7 to 2
the Supreme Court held that Dred Scott
was not a citizen of the United States
and so therefore he could not bring his
freedom suit before federal court which
is really a jurisdictional question but
then the court also goes on to
invalidate the Missouri Compromise
despite finding that it lacked
jurisdiction to hear the case what
happens when the case is being argued is
that one of the arguments that's
introduced is this idea that when Scott
had been taken into free territory he
wasn't necessarily free because the
Missouri Compromise was unconstitutional
and so what the court ends up doing is
not only ruling on the status of Scott
but also on the status of slavery in
these federal territories in the West
and the extent of the powers of Congress
over slavery in the West
interesting so Chief Justice Roger tawny
is then leading the Supreme Court and he
I guess leads the reasoning about this
case so what were some of the arguments
that he eventually accepted and made in
his decision so Chief Justice tani is a
very interesting figure he had been on
the court for many years he in his early
years had been moderately anti-slavery
had freed most of his own slaves and had
made anti-slavery statements but by 1857
Tawney reflected the larger change that
had taken place within his political
party Tony was a Democrat and the
Democratic Party had become more
southern dominated and more pro-slavery
and tawny then by 1857 really is a
symbol of pro-slavery southern thought
Justice tani opinion is somewhat
notorious he makes a series of arguments
and one is legal the others are really
not legal arguments as I'll explain so
what he starts out by saying is that
just because you're a citizen of a state
that that does not make you a citizen of
the United States he says basically the
federal government is the exclusive has
exclusive authority to decide who is a
citizen of the United States then he
makes a second argument and he says even
if Dred Scott were a citizen of the
state of Missouri he would not be a
citizen of the United States because
he's black and what he meant by that is
that the word citizen has used in the
Constitution and the Declaration of
Independence categorically excluded
members of the Negro race this is
fascinating because it seems to me like
Justice tani may have been kind of
ignoring a long history of free people
of color in the United States who had
voting rights who had property rights he
was and that was part of the criticism
of the majority opinion that comes in
especially the dissent written by
justice Benjamin Curtis Curtis had the
lengthier of the two dissents and the
more thorough legal argument because as
you point out that in five states at the
time of the founding that African
Americans did exercise the right to vote
that was a sign or some sort of an
indication of their status as citizens
and so the argument made by justice
Curtis then is that Toni's reading of
history was that the founders had not in
tended for African Americans to be part
of the people or the citizens that were
referred to in the text of the US
Constitution what Justice tani has done
here as you know basically created a
blind spot for himself and he goes on to
point out that this is not his belief
this belief in Negro inferiority but he
said that it was a fixed and universal
belief
then the civilized portion of the white
race he said it was an axiom a truth but
what's interesting is that he says this
without a citation he says that these
aren't his views these are the views of
the framers the great men who were high
in literary accomplishment high in their
sense of honor
he said that they perfectly understood
the language that they used and how it
would be understood by others and
there's this great quote in the opinion
where he says that they the framers knew
that it would not in any part of the
civilized world be supposed to embrace
the Negro race which by common consent
had been excluded from civilised
governments and the family of nations
and doomed to slavery what Justice tani
has done here is he's attempted to
rewrite history so how did the American
people respond to the Dred Scott
decision at large were they generally
for it or aghast by it well as you might
expect things were split exactly down
the middle
what we see in the south is white
Southerners believed that the ruling is
a vindication of what they had been
arguing southerners had been arguing for
many years going back to John C Calhoun
that southerners and that southern
slaveholders had a bundle of Rights and
they argued that they had the right to
own slaves as property in the southern
states they argued that they had a right
to recapture fugitive slaves who escaped
into the north and they also argued that
they had a right to take slaves into the
West and so southerners then feel that
the court and the US Constitution are on
their side you see a lot of folks in the
north who are hostile to what the court
has done because once again they see it
as further evidence that the court is
dominated by the Democratic Party by the
slave power and many of these folks then
are going to be members of a new party
and that was of course the Republican
Party I think the abolitionists were
furious and I think Frederick Douglass's
statement
calling it a brazen misstatement of
facts of history a scandalous and
devilish perversion of the Constitution
resonated even future presidential
candidate Abraham Lincoln that sought
that same summer that the case was
decided went out and denounced it
publicly so Lincoln of course wins the
election of November 1860 which becomes
a precipitating event of the Civil War
do you see the Dred Scott decision as
being a really important cause of the
Civil War
yes so these things are all linked
absolutely think about the ruling by
Tony and rich guy ruling that
slaveholders rights are absolute Tony
rules african-americans have no rights
slaveholders have total rights this
makes it possible for Lincoln to rise as
a sort of political leader in the north
because he has something that he can
strongly criticize because Lincoln
basically makes the argument that the
founders had hoped for slavery to
disappear ultimately and Tony's making
exactly the opposite argument so the
interesting thing is if you sort of
think about how this story sort of ends
it ends in March of 1861 when Abraham
Lincoln is sworn in as the 16th
president and who swears him in of
course Roger be tawny so between the
time when Lincoln was elected in
November of 1860 and the time when he
takes that oath of office in March of
1861 7 southern slaveholding states
those are the states that leave the
federal Union first for other states of
course will join them but not until
after the Civil War has already started
so there's no compromise of 1860 in
stead what we get is a four-year long
civil war where more than 620,000
Americans are killed and at the end of
that war the north the United States is
victorious
and slavery in the 13th amendment is
abolished forever so how does the end of
the civil war relate back to the Dred
Scott case the Thirteenth Amendment end
slavery the the 14th amendment has to
sort of undermine or overturn the other
part of the Supreme Court's ruling which
was this issue of the rights of those
who previously had been held as slaves
and the 14th amendment then is going to
do that work by stating that all who
were born in this country by virtue of
their birth here are citizens and that
they have rights that will be protected
by the federal government and if you
think about it what what has changed
what has shifted is the whole sort of
national discourse of rights from the
emphasis on the rights of slaveholders
that we see in 1857 to an emphasis on
the rights of those who previously had
been held as slaves and arguably than
what we see really during the Civil War
and reconstruction is the advent of a
new sort of discourse focusing on human
rights and that I would argue is
profoundly significant so what happened
to Dred Scott after this did he and his
wife live to see the end of the Civil
War and the end of slavery unfortunately
Dred Scott did not the Supreme Court
renders its decision in 1857 but he dies
unfortunately in 1858 his wife Harriet
though lives on - about 1876 so she did
live to see the end of the Civil War and
the end of slavery the Dred Scott case
made clear at the time that the struggle
for citizenship and of course the later
struggle for civil rights is about the
desire to be treated with equal dignity
to be viewed as possessing equal
humanity and what is perhaps most moving
I think about the Dred Scott case is the
dignity with which the
gods carried themselves throughout the
entire ordeal despite the court's best
efforts to deprive them of that dignity
it was ultimately Dred and Harriet who
gained the respect of the nation and it
was the inhumanity of the court and the
institution of slavery that was laid
bare for all to see
so we've learned that the ruling in Dred
Scott helped bring about the Civil War
by further dividing the north and south
over the issue of slavery opposition to
the cases outcome propelled Abraham
Lincoln to the national political stage
and opposition to Abraham Lincoln
propelled slave states to secede after
his election as president but the Dred
Scott case was also about the lives and
fates of one man and his family
although Dred didn't survive to see the
end of slavery and the passage of the
14th amendment granting equal
citizenship to African Americans his
family lived to see the rewards of the
struggle he began to learn more about
the Dred Scott case visit the National
Constitution Center's interactive
Constitution and Khan Academy's
resources on US history